a group of parents who were deported
from the US are back in America after an
unprecedented court ruling CBS News
exclusively captured one family's
emotional reunion take a look at this so
let me explain what's going on here that
is seven-year-old Alison hugging her dad
Fernando early this morning at Los
Angeles International Airport his wife
and two other daughters also could not
contain their excitement Fernando was
deported in August of 2018 after being
detained at an ice facility in Georgia
he is one of nine parents who were
allowed back into the United States
after a federal court ruled they were
given false information that ultimately
led to their deportation so they haven't
seen each other in close to two years 7
Alison it's it's really good to see them
back together they should not you know
what is interesting the judge found that
not only had these families been given
false information they've been coerced
in some cases into waiving their rights
this is it's very flawed what is
happening to these families to be
separated out this way then they hear
that it's false information that's
that's not good we're address of a yes
we're happy that we were there to
capture that much yes